I'm here at the Berlin Tempelhof Airport
this is an iconic site one of the most
famous airports in the world it was the
scene of the Berlin Airlift between 1948
and 1949 Berlin was cut off from the
rest of the world and this city was fed
by the West Plains landed here every 30
to 45 seconds to bring valuable food
medical supplies and it helps saved West
Berlin Tempelhof is again playing a
pivotal role because right now 1,500
refugees are living here refugees from
Afghanistan Syria Iraq Iran so many
hoping to either go back one day to
their own homes where it'll be peaceful
and safe or possibly to assimilate so I
want to go in I want to talk to them and
find out what's going on hello my name
is Conan women Union where are you from
I'm from Palestine Palestine oh you're
from Syria what do you study but in one
of the nicest could you see yourself
living here in Germany do you think yes
because it's a family in big city and
they have different people from
everywhere from Naropa from America from
Arabic country and I like I'm standing
here with gentlemen from Afghanistan how
long have you been here at Tempelhof
and what do they do while they're here
at Temple Hoffman amongst employee yes
we have winter snow could you ask them
if there is one message they would like
to get out to the world what would that
be okay Solano on machine a nice tan
hello madam Obama supervenience I got
not only the long run was more than was
that one of them was I don't know the
good news is that most people in their
hearts understand that is their hope to
one day go home to a peaceful
Afghanistan maybe a mother giving us
time it's interesting because they're
living in a city now Berlin that was
completely destroyed by war and yet this
city grew back and is more vibrant
stronger more diverse than ever and I
think that would be a great message of
hope to people from Afghanistan so
what's your favorite sport I am an
amazing dancer when I dance 14 question
is everyone else jealous of his amazing
mustache you want that mustache you want
that
with the magic of television I can give
you that moustache if you look right at
that camera right now
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
you
you